when i first
read the script written by brad inglesby
it completely took my breath away
every episode ends on a real cliffhanger
i sat up till the early hours of the
morning reading every single episode
i had never read a character who was
able to pull off so much in terms of how
she
copes how she deals with people and
she's extraordinary at her job so i
felt enormous admiration for a person
like that
kate wanted to pursue the character in a
way that
was lovely as a writer to have someone
who wants to put in the time like that
and dig
deep eventually it became kate's
creation i trusted her to make dialogue
changes because i felt convinced that
she knew this character
better than i did kate was constantly
adding things i mean
we would rehearse the scene block the
scene and then
she would say mara would probably just
do this or like
should i be eating something like some
junk food
like how do we make a new iteration of
it that's even more
mayor it's definitely been i'd say
one of if not the most challenging role
i've ever played just because of how
enormous it was the sheer volume of
story
the number of characters and then the
dialect
all right everybody get your gloves on
do a grid search
mark anything seems out of place so we
can photograph it
anyone from delaware county will know
that the dialect
is very complicated it's a very subtle
one which makes it harder to pick up and
it can also
sound southern if you don't do it right
there were certain check-in words that i
would have
like water get your water bottle ready
the trickiest part
are the o's going home alone on my own
which is very different to going home
alone on my own you need to walk out of
here and go home
and every once i'd say brad you give me
seven o's in this one line
i don't know what that'll say oh wait it
just came to me
that was stupid goddamn idiotic
if you're working on a dialect you can
start with the sound changes
you can start with the rhythms you can
start with certain melodies you can
start anywhere
you just chip away at it until you
eventually can pull the whole thing
together
kate really does have this prodigious
work ethic
we just drilled it and worked it and it
was constant
she was utterly committed to doing this
well to doing it properly to honoring
the local culture
and being able to shoot locally like
that is very helpful we were really
trying to be as specific as we could to
the area
in addition to that we would like do it
with costume our custom designer would
be texting me pictures from the wawa
convenience store
just of people in the line we would
spend
so much time distressing every item of
clothing with scrubbing brushes and
pulling holes in things and all her
clothes feel like clothes they don't
feel like costumes
i told the costume designer that i
wanted to wear hip pads
and butt pads and she practically cried
she was so happy she said
actress is never asking for that oh
we're just asking anyone who knows
anything to please
come forward maybe it's a serial killer
oh christ mom i mean it is the third
girl mayor
a thing that became clearer to me while
making the show
was that we were really talking about
people who had been affected by trauma
trying to learn to move on from their
trauma
there's a scene where siobhan comes home
that's when
all of the things that she hasn't been
able to say or hasn't been allowed to
say
come out you don't even tell are you
telling me we don't even talk about him
anymore
and i hate you for that i hate you you
just want to find him
not me not me when i first read that
scene in the script i just
cried sometimes as an actor it's just
horrible shooting certain scenes
and that scene was very upsetting and uh
extremely painful
kate and gauri and i had a conversation
about what is
going to make us feel like we've
achieved a real moment
maybe have less people on set and not
necessarily have the time pressure that
we would have in a
different scenario it was very kind of
intimate and personal
it was just heartbreaking to film it was
very hard
to differentiate between wanting to
support and help and gary in performing
the scene
and having to also keep so much reserved
because that's how mayor handles the
scene
kate as an actor she's so able to just
cover a gamut of emotions and qualities
where you can see mare being super
focused on the work she's doing but at
the same time he's able to sort of
very closely under the surface he's a
very vulnerable woman who needs to be
loved and wants to love too
yeah i think this was kind of a one-time
thing what does it have to me
my life's complicated it was really
clear for me to see
where richard would fit into her life
and what was required
to be some sort of relief for mayor do
you ever give yourself a break
are you about to tell me i look
exhausted no but it seems like
you're carrying a lot of heavy stuff and
i
you know i wonder if anybody ever does
anything for you
we are dealing with dark and tragic
events in the show
but i think in order for an audience to
want to stick around each week it can't
be too
heavy all the time and so this show has
a lot of humor in it
there's a scene where evan says
goodnight mayor
and in one of the rehearsals the way he
delivered it he was like have a good
nightmare
good night mary i want you to have a
good nightmare
craig and i thought that was absolutely
hilarious and i was like wait just say
that the next time and so we
shot some of these things that ended up
in the show and messing around and kind
of finding it on set
the first scene i shot was was fun it's
where we're at the funeral
listen up and then he announces out of
guilt in front of everyone at his wife's
wake
i had an affair with helen fahey
in spite of these tragic events there's
a lot of laughter in this community
listen affair's a strong word very
strong it happened twice
three times tops the main pot sequence
was a
particularly fun sequence to design the
location that we found
was relocation that was a bar in the
front and a house in the back
the set decoration was incredible and
just looked so real
and scary logistically we had to really
understand the space
we had to understand exactly what would
happen to evan i think they did a
countdown like three
two one bang they shot
me doing that and then set up a
pyrotechnic that had blood in it and
then
shot that going on the wall and then the
rest of the day i had a bullet hole in
my face and i was laying on the ground
it was running all around my head i'm
like please don't step on me
i had never held a gun before playing
this part
we didn't want her to come off as an
action star
we wanted to make sure that it read as
an unusual event
in the life of mareshian the hardest
part of any mystery show really is
sticking the landing
the ending has to be surprising and yet
it has to be rewarding as well
i was not able to predict what was
coming which is exciting you want to be
a part of something where you don't know
what's coming next
i always like theorize about who done it
and i never get it right so i was very
shocked
in a small town you have the opportunity
to sort of investigate all the families
and to see the effects that the crime
has had and get involved in everybody's
personal stories
a suspect is wanted in a murder
investigation
the truth comes out and then the worst
thing in the world that you can imagine
as a mother happens i think that moment
in the car
where laurie blows up at mayor she's
been holding on to so much that it's
just a moment where it all
comes out why couldn't you just leave it
alone it's my
ryan my ryan laura's life is completely
ruined because mare figures it out
we wanted to make sure that landed as a
surprise and a twist but that you would
have
empathy for characters that you didn't
before we worked so hard to keep it a
secret
i hope that the audience is as blown
away as we all were
by who the real killer is
you